ARCHULETA ATKINS BELL FOR AGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY
DODD DORADO GALGIANI GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO HURTADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK. SEND CAN. YOU KNOW
ROSS RUBIO SKINNER NUMBER RIGHT
CASKEY WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATORS BATES GLAZER
MORALE AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WELCOME SENATORS THE
CENTERS WILL PARTICIPATE IN
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE WILL BE
DISSIPATING AND A- BALL OR HOLD
ON MEASURES. OUR MEMBERS.
BEYOND PLEASE AND GALLERY FIVE
WILL BE. I SHOULD REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
BREAUX. COLLEAGUES AS WE MOURN
OUR REPRESENTATIVE CONGRESSMAN
JOHN LEWIS. AND IN MY HOME TOWN
LONG BEACH MAYOR'S MOTHER
GABRIELLE O'DONNELL. ALLEGIANCE
SENATE PRAYER. LOVING AND
MERCIFUL GOD THE GOSPEL
ACCORDING TO MATTHEW TELLS US
THAT THE MUSTARD SEED THE
SMALLER PAUL THIS IS BUT WHEN
IT OWN THE GREATEST OF PRIDE.
THIRTY THIRTY TWO. STERN SEAT
OF JUSTICE NEVER MIND THE
SMALLEST EVER WITNESSED THE
WOUNDS ARE DEEP THE SICKNESSES
AWFUL THE HUNGER IS GREAT BUT
WE ARE MUSTARD SEED OF HEALING
AND JUSTICE IMMEASURABLE DIVINE
FOR. OUR COURAGE IN LOVE IT'S
NOT ABOUT US. IT'S ABOUT THE
POWER RELEASED WHEN WE ARE SEWN
IN THE DAYS OF THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF THE CROSS EVEREST WE
ARE SO. AND WITH YOUR HELP WE
WILL BE PROCEEDS OF LEADERSHIP
JUSTICE AND LOVE FOR THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE. I'M IN. YEAH YEAH.
AND. IT WILL. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT HUMAN BEING A
GREAT. HUMANITARIANS LEADER IN
THAT IN THE PERSON OF JOHN
ROBERT LOUIS CAN WE HAVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS FROM MOVING TO THE
PRIVILEGES FLOOR THERE ARE NINE.
MESSAGE FROM GOVERNOR'S WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS FROM CONNECT COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AROUND RESOLUTIONS ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS. FILE ITEM PICKER.
ANY KNOWS MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE HAVE. SINCE THE
CENTER MELENDEZ- THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT ESSERE NINETY
THREE A MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO
RESTORE THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
INSTILLED BUT THERE ARE
CONSTANT MOTION WHAT IS YOUR
MOTION. MAKING A MOTION TO HAVE
WITHDRAWAL ESSERE NINETY THREE
FROM THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
TO BE TAKEN UP WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THE MOTION
IS. WITHDRAWN AT SEA ARE NINETY
THREE CORRECT CORRECT. CALDERON.
ALLEN. YEAH NOTE THE MAJORITY
LEADER SESSION FOR A NO VOTE. A
SMALL IN DISASTER FOR YES I AM.
MS JONES IS ASKING CENTER JONES
AS RIVAL SEARCH PROJECTION FOR
NOBLE. ALLEN ARCHULETA OH NO
ATKINS NO WELL. NO FORGES.
BRADFORD NO NO BECAUSE I AT A-
NO OKAY. I VALLEY HI DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME. NO GALGIANI NO
GONZALEZ NO GROWTH. I HERTZBERG.
NO HILL NO WAY SO KNOWN FOR
TADO NO JACKSON NO JONES I
LEYVA NO MCGUIRE NO MELENDEZ. I
MITCHELL NO MONNING NO MORE
LOCK HI NIELSEN. I PAN NO
PORTANTINO. NO ROTH. NO ROOF.
NO SKINNER. I'M BURKE WELL NO
WAY CASKEY. NO WIENER. NO WILK
HI. MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OUR NO GORGEOUS FIVE
I DODD. SKINNER THE.
MEMBERS
HIGHS NINE KNOWS TWENTY FIVE
THE MOTION FAILS. MOVING ON.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT- I MOVED JOINT RULE
SIXTY TO EIGHTY WAIT FOR THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE TO HEAR SIMPLY
BUILD NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX ON
SATURDAY AUGUST FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY WITHOUT NOTICE AND THE
DAILY FILE. ANY ACTION THAT.
JONES HERE JACKSON ASKED FOR
ROLL CALL VOTE AND- QUESTION NO
BUT PLEASE OKAY. SERVICE CENTER
ARTS PROJECTION FOR YES VOTE
SENATOR JONES AS FOR NOBLE
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ALLEN HI I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL I
FORGES NO BRADFORD PART I HAVE
A I DON'T. I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD. THEY'RE AWESOME. I
GALGIANI I GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
AND HERTZBERG NO I ASSUME.
TATTO AYE AYE JACKSON. I JONES
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL I MONEY I MORE LOCK
NO NIELSEN NO HAN ARE HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO HI
I SKINNER. I'M BURKE- I LIKE
OWSKI I WIENER HI WILK. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. CHECK DODD. GROWTH NO
WAY SO BY I SKINNER. WELL.
PRICE TWENTY FIVE NO SEVEN THE
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE WE
HAVE SECOND READING FILE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. THANK
YOU MOVING ON NOW TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT WE HAVE ITEMS FIVE
NINE SYNDROME WHAT ARE YOU
PREPARED. THERE WILL. TAKE THE
MISSED FIRST FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JOE
L. GOMEZ TO THE COMMISSION THE
STATUS OF WOMEN GIRLS MS COLE
MISSES THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER CHILDREN'S HOME START.
IN OFFICERS UNDERSTAND WORKING
COMMISSION STATUS OF WOMEN SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE COMMITTEE
ON THE SEVENTY TWO JUNE I
RESPECTFULLY. PER NIGHT ABOUT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
ON THIS APPOINTMENT. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROLE AS
CHAIR OF COURSE ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I HAVE A I
CHIANG HI DOLLY. DODD THERE ARE
OTHER. HI GALGIANI I GONZALEZ
HI GROW. I HEARD AYE HERTZBERG
AYE HILL I LISTEN FIVE I HER
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL I MONEY. I WARLOCK
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO HI I SKINNER.
NUMBER NINE HI MY COUNTY I
WIENER HI WILK I MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST HI
DOLLY. DODD JONES. MULLIN MORE
LAW I NIELSEN. SKINNER. VICE
THIRTY NO ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON NOW TO
FOLLOW SIX ZERO. MEMBERS
SERRATION IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX WHICH IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF BRIAN JOHNSON. MERECE AND
TREATMENT TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD THESE
APPOINTEES WERE MOVED ON ANIMUS
VOTE IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE SEVENTEENTH OF
JUNE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOTH. THE FOR THE
SCRIPT ON THIS APPOINTMENT-
SCENE. WHEN SECTOR PLEASE.
ALLEN AYE AYE ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I TELL. I FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM I CHIANG
HI DOLLY HI DODD. THEY'RE
AWESOME HI HI GALGIANI I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO. HI TADO I
JACKSON HI JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING I MORE LOCK I
NIELSEN HI PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. NUMBER
I LIKE HOW TO SKI HI WIENER AYE
WILK. HI. I'M SURGERY PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS DODD. GRAY.
I SKINNER. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN CENTERS
NEAR ME WELCOME SIR. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
JANET RILEY UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BORDER REGIONS MISS
RILEY IS A CO FOUNDER AND
BOARD. OF CLINIC THE BAY WHICH
PROVIDE CARE FOR UNINSURED
ADULTS IN SEPT IS KOBE. SHE'S
OFF- AND CALMNESS OF THE NOT IS
THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF JANET RILEY- FOR
CONFIRMATION TO THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA BOARD RE I HAVE
KNOWN- IS RUNNING FOR A LONG
TIME. CHOOSE A- IN A LEAD
NUMBERS. SHE HEARD KOTEL CLINIC
BY THE BAY WHICH IS A VERY
INNOVATIVE- MODEL FOR PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE TO OUR LOWEST
INCOME. SEE ALSO I SERVED AND I
SERVED WITH HER ON THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY ENTRANCE
DISTRICT WHERE SHE SERVED AS
CHAIR FORWARD AND TO AN EXTENT
JOB SHE'S KIND OF PERSON WHO
RISES LEADERSHIP I AM WHATEVER
ORGAN SEASON WITH ON. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER THIS. BASED ON THE
POINT. MMHM SEEN NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BELL. I FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I CHIANG. THE ALLEY.
DODD THEY'RE AWESOME ONE I
GALGIANI HI GONZALEZ. HI GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL. HUESO I AYE
HURTADO HI JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ.
NO MITCHELL. I MONEY I MORE
LOCK NIELSEN PAM HI I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. ON THE LINE I WE
COUNTY HI WIENER AYE WILK I. I
AM SURGERY CALLED UP TO MEMBERS
WHEN WE'RE DONE. CHIANG SALLY.
DODD GREAT. HELLO HI I MORE
LOCK I NIELSEN. SKINNER I'M
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ONE
MORE TIME. CHIANG DALLY. DODD
GROWTH NO NIELSEN. NO SKINNER.
ALL EYES TWENTY EIGHT MILLS FOR
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING ON NOW TO FALL ITEM
EIGHT CENTER WILL. HE MISSED
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
IS A- OF RUN TO CRAFT AS
INSPECTOR GENERAL OF THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
INVESTIGATIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT. DISPUTATION PRIOR
TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISS CRAFT
SERVICE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
TRAFFIC SAFETY AT THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY SHE WAS
APPROVED IN THEM. THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY JUNE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. HEARING SEEN NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
TELL I FOR JUST. I BRADFORD I
BECAUSE I ADAM HI CHIANG. HI
DOLLY I DODD. THE RISER ON I
GOT JOHNNY HI GONZALEZ. HI ROSE.
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL HI HI
LISTEN. HI TANTO HI JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S HI MITCHELL. I MONEY
HI MORE LOOK I NIELSEN. I CAN I
KNOW. ROB I RUBIO HI I SKINNER
NUMBER NINE I MY COUNTY BY
WIENER. HI WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE IS A CONFIRMATION
OF HILLARY NORTON TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION MS
NORTON IS EXACTLY DIRECT FIX
ANGELINO STUCK IN TRAFFIC.
REYES PASSED ME DE T. LA XIN
MANAGEMENT ORGANISED GENSHE
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY THIRD
JUNE I'M- FULLY ASK FOR. THANK
YOU THE FURTHER DISCUSSION
SENATOR FOR. MISTER PRESIDENT I
HAVE KNOWN THE NOMINEE FOR MANY
YEARS OF EVEN BEFORE SHE WAS
THE STAFF TO THEN COUNCILMAN
RICHARD ALATORRE SHOES WERE FOR
MARK THE THOMAS AND RICHARD
DOLLAR CON AND THE LIKE. AND I
AT THE OP EARLY IN MY MANY
YEARS INVOLVED IN THE VERY
FACETS OF LOOK SERVICE TO WORK
WITH AND BY SIDE OF MANY
TALENTED PEOPLE. NORTON ONE OF
HARD WORKING INNOVATIVE RATE OF
P. THIS IS THE TOP OF THAT
LIST. AND I JUST WANT TO HEAR
WITH MY COLLEAGUES. THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST IN THE POOR. YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE A DYNAMICALLY. IN
THE AREA OF PUBLIC POLICY
THAT'S CREDIT TO CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY STAND IN SUPPORT OF
HER NOMINATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO. CARE I RISE TO
SUPPORT OF MS NORTON I HAVE
KNOWN HER FOR MANY YEARS AND
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT SHE
HAS A VERY IS NOT JUST AT THE-
HIGHER LEVELS OF POP. BUT SHE'S
ACTUALLY. ON THE CROWN.
FIGHTING FOR SIMPLE THINGS LIKE.
RIGHT NUMBER OF LET WHICH
DIRECTION GOING TO SAY YOU
COULD TRY TO DEAL WITH ALL THE
TRAFFIC- AND I ESPECIALLY
WORKED. WITH HER WHEN SHE
FOUNDED THE UP ON DELAY STUFF
INTO AS YOU AND- SO. AND I'M
VERY PROUD OF I'M PROUD THAT
SHE'S TO BE ON THE COMMISSION
AND SHE'S GONNA. NORMS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU YOU
FURTHER DISCUSS ORDER ON A
POINT. IN SEEN NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
TELL. I FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI KAY. DALLY DODD.
THEIR EYES. I GALGIANI AYE
GONZALEZ HI ROSE. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. HURTADO I
JACKSON I JONES LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. WELL NO
MITCHELL. I MONEY. I MORE LOCK
NIELSEN PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER NUMBER
NINE FIVE FOUR CASKEY HI WIENER
AYE WILK I SECTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. CHIANG DALLY.
DODD GROSS. GRAYSON JONES. MORE
LOCK HI NIELSEN. SKINNER. VICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBER
THAT COMPLETES THE DAILY FILE
THIS IS A TIME IF THERE'S ANY
ANNOUNCEMENTS- COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO ANY. SENATOR
JACKSON'S THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT APPOINTED TOURNAMENT
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE BILLION
NOTED. ANY ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER MELENDEZ
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT LIKE TO SPEAK
ON CONDITION OF THE FILE IF I
MAY. CAN DO BOB THANK YOU
PROJECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS. I ASKED TO WITHDRAW AS
C. OR NINETY THREE TODAY FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS NUMBER ONE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO RESTORE
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES IN
STILL WITHIN OUR CONSTITUTION
BY TAKING BACK THE YOU KNOW
WHAT TROLL KERR. WHERE GOVERNOR
CALIFORNIA THIS THIS RESOLUTION
CURRENTLY BEING HELD IN THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. CURRENT
SITUATION IN THE INVOLVING
LEGISLATIVE IN COMMITTEE
HEARING SCHEDULES THE
RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT EMBODIES THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE LA YOU KNOW WHO CAUTIONED
US AND SAID. JEALOUSLY GUARD
OUR CON. ALL THREE AND LIKE
MANY OF YOU. THE GOVERNOR'S
PREACHER FORTY THAT IS THE
REASON I ASKED TO REMOVE THE
RESOLUTION FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND AT LEAST HAVE IT
ROBUSTLY DEBATED WITHIN A
WITHIN A COMMITTEE SO I THINK
YOU FOR A- EIGHTY TO EXPLAIN MY
MOTION. THANK YOU CENTER
MELENDEZ ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
VERY. THERE'S NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS THE DOSE
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH HI
I WOULD JUST SAY- WE WILL
ADJOURN UPON COMPLETION OF
TODAY'S BUSINESS AND RECONVENE
MONDAY AUGUST THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL ALL OF THIS
BUSINESS BEEN A THE DESK WILL
BE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT
TWO PM.